mike his birthday's coming up of course
father's day what do you and the kids
have up your sleeves no
harry i don't know it's brainstorm
girlfriend i know
what do you like to do for the day well
so we we
rarely have date nights and it's all my
fault because i'm like man then i'm
gonna have to put on like
something cute like jeans or something
and
i i don't want to um and also
i i yeah i would rather just make dinner
for the family and
eat there so i'm probably just gonna
take him off for a date night which is
it's rare i know we should do it more
often but you know
busy parents yeah just like so many out
there miss carrie thank you for joining
us today and thank you for letting us
crash your party here at dick's house of
sport this place is
unbelievable it is it was super fun too
just talking to
people about like what they wanted and
they were talking about how
much they wanted it to be like a hub for
the community and have like
sports camps here you know for kids on
the field and stuff and i'm like wow
what a
what what a way to go above and beyond
for you know the place that you're in
it's not just
a store it's right they want it to be a
part of the community which is really
cool which is awesome and i feel like
you kalia have been a part of this new
female empowering and and health kick
kind of community as well i mean
yeah you can wear the clothes for
working out but you also look really
cute just running errands
loving the athleisure wearing the
swimsuits and everything so good
but speaking of swimsuits summer is just
two weeks away and i feel like now is
the best time
to sit down chat with you of all people
about some fitness because girl those
swimsuits are coming out soon you know
it
but what is like the best piece of
advice that you can give folks that want
to get
back on track with some sort of workout
routine
i mean it's all about taking care of
yourself and i feel like especially over
the past
year we've learned that it's very it's
more important or we're realizing how
important it is
to just be a healthy individual and put
good things into your body so that it
can keep you
healthy yeah keep you going um and i
feel like that's where that's where we
come in you know we just want people to
be their best we want to meet you where
you are and we want to be a part of your
journey
um as you know all of our kalia team and
and i love to see you know our line
evolve and
um you know we we listen to the people
that are coming in
and shopping and what do you what do you
need us
for you know we want to be there for
when you're in the gym but
we want to make help make women's lives
easier and
you know i i'll throw my clothes on i
feel good
going to drop my kids off at school and
then come back for a workout and
like i don't feel like i have to do a
wardrobe change in in the middle of the
day
you know so good yeah you know you feel
good about yourself going into the gym
and going and doing whatever
else it is that you need to do yeah
isn't that important though i feel like
okay you got to start somewhere when it
comes to your fitness
but there's something about looking oh
so cute in the process that just like
gets you in that fitness mentality gives
you that motivation
so how does a cute outfit for your
workouts really keep you motivated
for me i i do enjoy like working out in
front of a mirror because i want to see
my form i want to see what's going on
and
i feel like when i put things on that i
already feel good about myself in
then you know watching myself do you
know certain things in the mirror i'm
like oh you know
i just it it helps you up your game a
little bit
and it gives you some energy i love
bright colors too
if it's raining outside i will pick the
brightest colors in my
my kalia section of my closet and i feel
like that helps me for some reason if
i'm putting on like bright like orange
kind of colors or this color here it
just
kind of gives you a little extra extra
boost without a doubt you're like the
sun may not be out but i'm bringing the
sunshine i don't need it
if i'm wearing it i love it i love it
now kalia's mantra is one of many
mantras of kalia is to stay
the path you always manage to stay the
path carry what keeps you
personally motivated i mean i think just
thinking about that that path is
it's not a narrow path it's a wide path
and it means that you
take care of yourself but you can enjoy
your life too and
as soon as whatever holiday is over with
you know get back on track and
get back to you like really taking care
of yourself it's all about balance
yeah like that's what we're that's what
we're all about you know if you're
you can't be like perfect and super
strict about everything all the time
it's all about living your life and
taking care of yourself and enjoying
yourself and all the things and
all the moments and everything in
between without a doubt but i feel like
that is
a challenge and maybe an excuse a lot of
us
give i'm too tired i'm too busy
i got too much to balance right now i've
got
guilt because i'm carving out time for
myself but how do you manage to carve
out time for yourself
and not have those excuses not have that
guilt it
is an act of self-care and i feel like
it's so important
that we as women do something for
ourselves
that it makes everything else
better like i feel like i'm a better mom
wife
friend daughter all the things if i do
carve out
a little time for myself to get my body
moving
it's good for your body it's good for
your mind it's good for your stress
levels and
there's there's no downside to moving
your body yeah and it makes everything
else in my day
easier if i just do that a little bit
and you know i my husband and i are very
supportive of each other
and like hey you know i got the kids you
go work out and then we like switch off
and
so it takes it takes a team you know and
we're all on the same page but
um in the end it's it's it's better for
both of us and
i i whenever i talk to people that it's
like oh you know i'm too tired i just
don't want to
i'm like you will never feel when you're
done
like even when i don't want to which
those days certainly happen
when i get my booty in the gym yes when
i'm done
i'm never mad about it you know what i
mean you feel accomplished yeah
and like oh my god like i just did it
even though i didn't want to right
and honey i'm the payoff is going to be
big you know i feel like after you look
at yourself
i mean of course anything takes time but
seeing the results
feeling the results you're like okay i'm
glad i put away those excuses
and threw the guilt away as well you're
sure for sure because it
it makes you better yeah every other
aspect you and mike have the most
adorable little guys isaiah and jacob
but how are you hoping that you're
instilling within them even though they
are young
like hey fitness is important well
isaiah's six and he definitely has
noticed you know and he picks up on it
and we talk
about things like food and drink in our
house and
and stuff like that when he i mean
they're kids they just want sugar all
the time
naturally right so so we'll have those
conversations and i'll be like buddy you
know
it it doesn't it makes your brain not
work as well so maybe
you've had enough like let's have
something healthy and
um so we talk about that and um and
and he's definitely noticed you know us
in the gym and he actually
a couple days ago wanted to go work out
with mike so mike took him in there and
obviously he's not like lifting weights
or anything like that but
i came in and to see if he needed me to
to take him out so that he could work
out and he was like watch my push-up and
he was like doing push-ups like a
boss like good job buddy way to go
they pick up on things they notice
things and they notice what you make a
priority
for sure exactly and i i'm glad and i'm
glad we can have those
you know open dialogues about health and
yeah and what that means and to put good
things into our bodies
and how that affects our brains and our
bodies and um so we we talk about it a
lot
i mean because without a doubt they're
picking up on these things at a young
age and they'll carry them
with them throughout their lives and it
also helps you know when i tell him why
we work out i'm like
i want to be around for you guys as long
as i can i don't want to miss anything
so you know that's why mommy and daddy
you know we might leave the house for
you know 30 45 minutes but um we'll be
back and
you know obviously they're being watched
but yeah
they know they know why we're not with
them all every second of every day
and then it allows you to be more
attentive when you are with them because
you've given something to yourself i
love that i love that approach in that
mentality
i also love the idea and we talked about
balance but honey
please tell me i know you you are you
love to put good stuff in
but please tell me you have the
occasional cheat day carrie underwood
oh for sure what is it what is that
cheap meal what is
something that you just love to you know
indulge in from time to time
uh well i mean recently you know we had
memorial day and
i actually got to go see my parents
which i haven't seen my dad since like
christmas of 2019 so it was really good
to go see them
and um you know we we have like a little
room
that we have some workout equipment and
it's just enough you know
i always bring my kalia with me so i can
get a workout in while i'm there
um but we had our cookout and i ate all
the things
because that's just what you do you
enjoy yourself and
um you know my my biggest
problem it's not a problem um i'm a
i like cheese and i i wish i didn't i've
been waiting for
some tests that i do at some point to be
like you really shouldn't have dairy
right i haven't gotten that yet um but
yeah that's that's kind of my
my thing you like my kryptonite honey
i'm right there with you girl without a
doubt not a sweets girl too much
but yeah you can keep this sweet stuff
but give me all the salts
everything all right fair enough i like
to hear that but it is life's all about
balance
yeah the cmt awards are just days away
and you carry are the most awarded
artists
in cmt history with
22 wins just a mere 22. congrats on that
front
but what does it mean to you especially
since it's coming from the fans
i mean that is i feel like the the best
part of
of these awards is that people i mean
i've
i was voted into this whole
life you know being being on american
idol and
for people to still put that much time
and effort into voting
and um i mean they they work really hard
so it's uh i see i see like twitter
parties and stuff like that people get
on and they're like let's
let's vote you know at this time let's
get together and do it and i think
that's so cool that is incredible i mean
i
honestly i forget that idol was even
your launching pad because you've done
so much and this was a long time ago it
was but your talent is just
off the charts and you you never
disappoint this year you're going into
the award show with two more nominations
with that video with john legend for
hallelujah so
what did it mean taking home you know
continuing the winning streak if you
will
i mean i'm always about padding the
numbers now
i it's such a beautiful song and it's it
was such a beautiful video
and um i'm just really proud that it was
nominated
and we'll see what happens um i get to
perform on the on the show with need to
breathe
so i'm excited about that um and it's
just
it's just a fun it's a fun night i look
forward to the days when
you know because it was always such a
party vibe right and we would all be
there and just all the crowd just having
a blast
i look forward to those days again but
i'm really excited
that you know got to perform with them
and um
just see see what happens you're heading
to vegas here soon
congratulations on that front yeah your
first ever time to have a residency
there and you had to add
six more dates because they sold out so
quickly yeah we we had such a
great response um because you never know
like i feel like when i'm on tour and i
know where i'm going places and
people will you know they're they're
coming to to see us
i was like oh man i just hope people you
know are excited as we are about us
being in making honey of course the
people are excited we've also been away
from all of it for a minute
right so we just kind of had this this
kind of void
that was like 2020 and everybody's kind
of easing back into it and i feel like
because i've talked to other artists
about this we're like oh man we hope
do people like remember us or like what
has everybody else been doing because we
i don't know is there's just this wall
that's been yeah been in front
of us for a while but honey you were
unforgettable do not doubt yourself at
all but
uh you know how is country kerry gonna
go a little
sin city vegas style how are you gonna
shake your wardrobe up i mean i feel
like it's already
spot on you always knock it out of the
park with a wardrobe but how are you
going to spice it up for sin city
i mean i feel like vegas is just all
about
you know grandness and just things being
over the top
and carrie you're already grand whenever
it comes to like your wardrobe for
performances you know so
well and i i feel like it's you know
it's all about it's going to be all
about the rhinestones all about the
fringe all about i i do
change wardrobe you know throughout
shows and whatnot anyway
so i feel like this is just going to be
a great opportunity to to be able to do
that but you know we just want to have
fun we want the audience to have fun and
so good it's going to be good i can't
wait to see what it's going to look like
and i mean you think you're going to get
emotional i mean you've been able to
perform at some of these award shows you
haven't had a crowd
they're pre-taped you're going to be
performing at the opry soon but what do
you imagine
those performances especially in vegas
live crowd
packed out sold out shows is it going to
be emotional for you
probably but in a nothing but
like giddy happy kind of way um
i mean i i do i feel you always hear
absence makes the heart grow fonder and
it it really is true especially when
you're just you're which i feel like
honestly it has probably made
so many of us just really appreciate
what we have so much
you can take it for granted for sure you
know you're living on a bus
and you're going from place to place and
i'm hauling my kids around and i'm like
man like this is really hard
i love those moments being on stage it's
it's so wonderful
but then when you when you don't have
any of that and you're just you know
sitting at home
looking at each other like wait what are
we like okay can i sing somewhere
can i like you know take my kids you
know action figures and like line them
up in front of me or something
and sing to them just like feel
something
something some sort of audience are the
uh the kids and am i gonna join you in
vegas
probably a little bit yeah yeah um yeah
they you know they'll be in school and
stuff like that and i don't want them to
to miss um if they don't have to but
how could i not and i feel like isaiah
is just really starting to understand
yeah things now well especially after he
was in the studio right right
right just like he sees his hot stuff
for sure without a doubt yeah he thinks
that's his song
little drummer boy is like his song
forever he practically wrote it i'm
pretty sure
he knows he knows of nobody else singing
it
but us let the kid believe that
right
you